[Applause]
you don't have to do this
[Music]
i feel the conflict in you
it's tearing you apart
my conscience is clear no
you still hurt i feel it you still hurt
let me get that for you mr kylo sir
is this what you always wear we're
meeting the supreme leader i dressed
appropriately but communicating through
the force that called for being
shirtless i it
it caught me by surprise enough of this
the supreme leader is waiting for us i
bet he has his shirt on
feels like we've been chasing the
resistance forever can't we just blow
them up or something
i don't get it
we don't all have force powers pal how
about you show some respect for a little
thing called manual labor why won't it
just work
big old battleships bad wiring
fired by a child
confident maintenance staff i told them
to have this fixed join me and let's fix
it i see what you're doing how about you
join me and we fix it can we just fix it
together
fine
but you will join me i saw it then when
we touched hands i saw your future just
the shape of it you will not bow before
smoke
you'll turn
i'll help you
i saw something too
because of what i saw i know when the
moment comes you will be the one to turn
you will stand with me rey
hey
how am i supposed to heat up this oil in
the dark
you can explain to the supreme leader
why you destroyed
get in
[Music]
young ray
come closer child
[Music]
you underestimate skywalker
and ben solo and me
[Music]
my worthy apprentice son of darkness
heir apparent to lord vader fulfill your
destiny
i know what i have to do
[Music]
um
[Music]
right you're doing okay
dude
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
that's fine
this is fine
don't worry about me
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you all got to wear helmets why couldn't
it
[Music]
get ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great i need you
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
the fleet there's still time to save the
fleet
ray
i want you to join me we can rule
together and bring a new order to the
galaxy don't do this ben join me
[Music]
[Music]
finn
you can actually do this right
cloaking our approach we should be off
their scopes